This is an amazing beginner's Angular course,
Slobodan is a very experienced developer.
And he teaches the basics of Angular, using
diagrams, animations, and of course code. Today,
I'm starting with a new video series about
Angular framework. And in this series,
you will learn all the things you need to master
Angular framework. I'll start with basic stuff
like components and pipes, and slowly progress,
the most complex features of this framework.
So let's start. In this section, I'm going
to explain what Angular is give some brief
overview of its features and explain why
you should use it. But before we start,
make sure to check my channel for more videos,
and tutorials about front end development. Now,
let's start. Angular is opinionated UI framework
for building mobile and desktop applications.
And it's built using TypeScript by Google.
You've probably heard about that one.
Also, it is an open source and helps us
build dynamic and single page applications.
It is completely based on components. It consists
of several components, which forms a tree
structure with parent and child components. Angles
versions beyond two plus are generally known is
angular only. The very first version of Angular
is known as Angular JS. So why Angular? Well,
because it's supported on various platforms,
web, mobile, desktop native, it's powerful,
modern, has nice ecosystem. And it's just cool
that the mist, let me give you some facts.
Angular presents you not only the tools, but
also design patterns to build your project in
a maintainable way. In an Angular application is
crafted properly, you don't end up with a tangle
of classes and methods that are hard to modify,
and even harder to test. The code is structured
conveniently, and you won't need to spend much
time in order to understand what is going on.
It's JavaScript, but better. Angular is built with
TypeScript, which in turn relies on GS ESX. You
don't need to learn a totally new language, but
you still receive features like static typing,
interfaces, classes, namespaces, decorators, etc.
No need to reinvent the bicycle. with Angular,
you already have lots of tools to start crafting
application. Right away. You have directives to
give HTML elements dynamic behavior, you can power
up the forms using form control and introduce
various validation rules. You may easily send
a synchronous HTTP requests various types, you
can set up routing with little hassle, and there
are many more goodies that Angular can offer us.
components are decoupled, angular strive to remove
the tight coupling between various components of
the application. injection happens no j style,
and you may replace various component VDS. All
DOM manipulation happens, where it should happen.
with Angular euren, tightly coupled presentation
and application logic, making your markup much
cleaner and simpler. Testing is at the heart.
Angular is meant to be thoroughly tested, and
it supports both unit and end to end testing.
Angular is mobile and desktop ready, meaning
you have one framework for multiple platforms.
Angular is actively maintained, and
has a large community and ecosystem.
You can find lots of materials on this framework,
as well as many useful third party tools.
The architecture diagram indentifies, the eight
main building blocks of an Angular application.
Angular apps are modular, and an
Angular has its own modularity system,
called Angular modules, or enshi. modules. Every
Angular app has at least one Angular module class,
the root module, conveniently named app module.
While the root module may be the only module
in a small application, most apps have many
more feature modules. Each a cohesive block
of code dedicated to an application domain, or
workflow are closely related set of capabilities.
in Angular module, whether a route or a feature
is a class with an NGO module decorator.
Angular templates are dynamic. When
Angular renders them it transforms the DOM
according to the instructions given by directives.
Metadata tells Angular how to process a class.
Service is a broad category encompassing any value
function or feature that your application needs.
Almost anything can be a service. A
service is typically a class with a narrow,
well defined purpose. It should do something
specific and do it well. Examples include
logging Service data service message bus
tax calculator application configuration.
There is nothing specifically about Angular
services. Angular has no definition of a
service. There is no service base class and
no place to register a service. Yet, services
are fundamental to any Angular application.
components are big consumers of services.
Now let's talk more about components in detail.
components are the main building block of Angular
application. Each component consists of an HTML
template that declares what renders on the page,
a TypeScript class that defines behavior, the
CSS selector that defines how the component
is used in our template, and optionally,
CSS styles applied to the component.
A component must belong to an NGO module in order
for it to be available to another component.
Why do we use components? There are many reasons
but the main ones are, you're able to reuse our
code so we don't duplicate simplify component
based architecture, easy to do error handling,
and breaking down the complexity into smaller
pieces. prerequisites for these sections are
install the angular COI, and create an Angular
workspace with the initial application.
If you don't have a project, you can create one
using mg new project name, where project name is
the name of your application. Although the angular
satellite is the easiest way to create an Angular
component, In this tutorial, we will create our
component manually. To create a new component.
Navigate to your Angular project directory.
Create a new file hello world component Ts file.
At the top of the file, add
the following import statement.
After the import statement, add a component
decorator decorator marks a class is an
Angular component in provides metadata that
decides how the component is use at runtime.
Choose CSS selector for the component. This is a
tag which you will be using in your template files
to render your component defined the HTML template
that the component uses to display information.
In most cases, this template is a separate HTML
file, but I'll use it within this file. To define
a template as external file. Add a template
URL property to the component decorator.
For a template within the same
file, use template property.
Select the styles for the components template.
In most cases, you will define the styles for a
components template in a separate file. Again, I
will use it within the file to declare the styles
for a component in a separate pile, or the style
URLs property to the Add Component decorator.
But for the styles within the
component, add styles property,
add a class statement that includes the code for
the component. Here we can define properties,
methods, catch component lifecycle events,
and do dependency injection. But I'll talk
more about these in the next video. Now, all the
public properties that are defined in the class
are accessible in the HTML template. And
this is one of the most powerful things here,
I'll create a title property, and
I will include it in the HTML.
import that new file in the
module where you want to use it,
to make it available for the whole app imported
in the root module. In order to see our component,
we can use our CSS selector inside of our app
component or any other component. And this is
your first component. Very simple though, you
can reuse across your area. In this section,
we are talking about lifecycle hooks. There are
special functionality in Angular that allows us to
hook into and run code. And a specific lifecycle
event of a component or director can look at them
as pages of component life. Like every living
being cast, they get born, they change, they grow,
and eventually they die. With lifecycle hooks,
you can gain better control of our application
when we want to use them. For example, if you want
to fetch some data in this page in your component,
you will do that inside of MG on in its lifecycle
when a component gets initialized, or if you
need to clean up your component remove some
subscriptions, you might have to prevent memory
leaks, you will do that inside of NGO ondestroy
lifecycle just before component gets destroyed.
This is the list of all hooks in exact order how
they get initialized, but most use ones are on it
on changes and ondestroy. let's implement the NGO
on it, hook it up. We'll be using this hook the
most first in input on an interface from Angular
core. Next, we want to implement this interface
inside of our class. To implement any hook, you
just need to add an energy to the interface name,
and you will get the method needed for
implementation. So in this case, it's mg on in it,
we will create a simple function for logging
some values to the console. Now, I will create
a property they will save that function so that
we can clean it up at the end. In the NGO on init
method, let's create a simple set interval method
which will make a console log on every second.
If you leave our component like this, when the
component gets destroyed, our interval method
will continue to log to console. To fix this side
effect, we need to use the NGO on destroy hook.
Import on destroy interface
in place the next on in it.
Now create the NGO ondestroy method and in this
method, you need to clean up this interval.
Simply use a clear interval method with
our property passed as an argument.
And now our component has been cleaned up.
Using lifecycle hooks, we're going to fine tune
the behavior of our components during creation,
update and destruction. Next, text interpolation.
Text interpolation in Angular is a one way data
binding technique that is used to transfer data
from a TypeScript code to an HTML template. It
uses the template expression in double curly
braces, also known as a mustache syntax to display
the data from the component to the view. When do
we need a text interpolation? Every time we want
to make something dynamic in our HTML template.
To illustrate how interpolation works, let's
create a new variable in our Ts class. You
can use interpolation to display the value of
this variable in the corresponding component
template. Angular replaces title with the string
value of the corresponding component property.
In this case, the values hello world. Now let's
talk about template expressions. A template
expression produces a value and appears within
double curly braces. Let me show you an example.
Angular resolves the expression and assigns
it to a property of a binding target. template
expressions are similar to JavaScript, except you
can't use assignments. Also operators such as new
type of or ease to solve. You can't use chaining
expressions decrement, or increment operators and
some of the ies 2015 plus operators. expressions
can also invoke methods. So let's create one
name of our method that will be get made.
And in this method, we are returning value
for displaying it in our template. In
this case, it will be a minimum value.
Couple of things I want to mention, you should
keep application logic in the component as much
as possible, where it is easier to develop and
test. Also, expressions should finish quickly
to keep the user experience as efficient as
possible, especially on slower devices. And
template expression should not change any
application state other than the value of
the target property. Reading a component value
should not change some other displayed values.
Now let's learn how to communicate
between the components.
in Angular application usually consists of
many separate components. And in order to make
them work together, we need communication
between them. You can think of components
as family members. And if communication between
the parents and kids is fluid and efficient,
your home will be a happy place. There are four
ways to communicate between the angular components
binding using input and output reference by using
view child and content provider using services
and templates outlined. In this tutorial,
I'm going to cover the first two ways
as we haven't covered services yet. And a
template out that is a little bit of that.
First use case is when we want to send data from
parent to child using input decorator. Input
decorator takes the value passed from parent
and stores that value in the child property.
Let me create two components using Angular CLA.
I will run the following commands and G generate
component parent and angiogenic component child.
In our child component, I
will import input decorator.
In name our input is child message of type string
In a template of the same component, I will
display this property which is going to be
passed from a parent. Now, inside of our parent
component in the template, we want to place our
child component and to pass the value to the input
property we just created. The name of the property
is the one we defined in the child component,
and the value is going to be a Hello message.
Next, we want to place our parent
component inside of our root component.
And if we preview it, we can see their message
from parent has been displayed in our child
component. Second use case is when we
want to send data from child to parent
using output decorator. Output decorator marks
a property in a child component is a doorway
through which data can travel from the child
to the parent. This approach is ideal when you
want to share data this occurs on things like
button quick form entries in other user events.
To raise it an event, an output must have the type
of event emitter, which is a class in the angular
core that used to emit custom events. In the child
component input output decorator an event emitter.
We declare a message event variable with the
output decorator and set it to equal to a new
event emitter. And then we create a function
named send message that calls a method on this
event with the message we want to send. Lastly,
we create a button to trigger this function.
In the parent, I will create a function to receive
the message and I will just simply alert
this message for demonstration purposes.
Now in the parent template, call our function
once the event from the child component occurs.
And the name of that event is the one
that we defined with output decorator.
Very simple and effective. Compared with
all other approaches for communication,
binding is the cleanest and the simplest one, it
is the most maintainable wait for passing data,
as binding is always the most preferable way
that Angular developers should consider first.
Third use case is when we want to send data
from child to parent using view child view child
allows the child component to be injected into a
parent component. It will give the parent access
to its properties and functions. Each child
won't be available to give access until the
viewer has been initialized. This means we need
to implement the after view init lifecycle hook
to receive the data from the child. First create
a message property in our child component.
Import view child in after view init.
From Angular core in our child component.
For our view, child decorator, pass our child
component as an argument in named as child.
Next, implement after view init lifecycle hook.
By the way to learn more about Angular hooks,
check the part two of this video series inside
the MG after view init method just alert the
message property of our child so that you
can see that we have access to it. And if we
start our application, you can see that we are
displaying a message from the child component.
Next, we are discussing component styles. Being
able to style your app is very important because
it allows you to make your app unique and
attractive. In a way it's like a beauty salon.
World Without CSS would be an ugly place. css
gives us the opportunity to play with a page
layout, adjust colors and fonts, add effects
images, and so on how to add styles to Angular
components. There are three ways you can apply
style by setting style or style URLs metadata,
in light the template HTML, and three with CSS
imports. I created one blank component with only
h2 tag in the view to demonstrate all different
ways we can style it. You can add a styles array
property to the component decorator, each string
in the array define some CSS for This component
can load styles from external CSS files by adding
a styles URL property to a components decorator.
And now styles from external
file are being applied. Next,
you can embed CSS styles directly into the HTML
template by putting them inside of style tags.
You can also write the link tags
into the components HTML template.
One note here is to be sure
to include the link styles
file among the assets to be copied
to the server when building.
You can also import CSS files into the CSS
files using the standard CSS import rule.
I usually use this approach to import variables.
Reminder, these styles apply only to this
component. So if you held h1 tag in a child
or parent component, it won't be applied there.
By default view encapsulation is said to emulated
and emulates the behavior of the Shadow DOM
by pre processing and renaming CSS code to
effectively scope the CSS to the components view.
We can remove these additional CSS selectors by
setting encapsulation to none. And now our styles
are being applied globally. Global styles are by
default defined in the style CSS file, and you can
find more global styles in the angular JSON file.
Another thing is that if you're building with
the COI, you can write style files in sass,
less or stylus, and specify those files in the
component style URLs metadata, be the appropriate
extension as in the following example. Now
let's talk about special selectors. Use the host
pseudo class selector to target styles in the
element that hosts the component is opposite to
target elements inside the components template.
For example, we can write the following code.
We can style host styles with the given selector
by using the function form as the following.
And if you add active class to host component,
you can see that styles are being applied.
Now let's talk about host context. Sometimes it's
useful to apply styles based on some condition
outside of the components view. For example, a
CSS theme class can be applied to the document
body element. And you want to change
how your component looks based on that.
The following example applies
a background color style to all
h2 elements inside of the component. Only if
ancestor element has the CSS class theme light.
Now if you go to root element, add theme
like class, you can see those styles.
And that's it. Now let's see what is mg content.
Anti content uses the content projection to take
HTML of another component and to displayed inside
itself. To me, it's similar to a film projector,
where you have a slot to insert your content,
which is going to be displayed on the screen.
It's a very powerful tool when you're
building components intended for reuse.
I see it used extensively in frameworks such
as NGO material. When do you want to use energy
content? anytime you want to inject any kind of
HTML into a component, you can do so mg content.
I have two components child and root component
to demonstrate this feature inside the child
component, I will create some static content.
So I'll add an h2 title. And below that title,
I want to show that dynamic content. So
I will create an mg content tag. With the
MG content element in place. Users of this
component can now project their own message
into the component. To do that, let me
insert a child inside of our root component
and I will pass paragraph in a message.
As you can see, the energy content element
is a placeholder that does not create a
real DOM element. Now, except single
a component can have a multiple slots.
Each slot can specify a CSS selector that
determines which content goes into that slot.
This pattern is referred to as
multi slot content projection.
You can accomplish this task by using the Select
attribute of Andry content inside of our child
component. add one more Angie content add, we
can make our component to be like a question and
answer card. So in the first entry content, add
question selector and put a second edgy content
add answer selector. Now, we can use the selectors
to send different content. In our route component,
I will create a stream title request
selector, and I will type this question text.
Below, I will create a paragraph get an answer
selector, and I will type an answer text.
Also, there are a couple other ways to create
multi slot content projection. But we haven't
covered conditionals yet. As you can see, it's
really easy to create reusable dynamic components.
This approach can be used for much more complex
user interfaces. But I showed you this simple
example to understand the concept. Next, let's
discuss template statements. A template statement
is something that responds to an event raised by
a target like an element component or directive.
So it's the same thing as if someone
is calling you, which is an event
and you're answering that phone call,
which is the response and in our example,
template statement. It commits side effects as
it changes the fields in the component. Now,
I will show you how to update class
properties. Using a template statement.
I have a blank component and in our template,
I will create a Boolean property named show
text in a value of false. Below that, I
will create a method named toggle text,
it's not going to return anything at this point.
All we are going to do here is to toggle our show
tax value on every method call. Usually, we would
use this kind of property to toggle the state
in the view, but we haven't covered
conditionals yet. So in the template,
I'm going to create a button which will respond on
a click event and it will call this toggle method.
Below that I will adjust the
state or show tax property.
And now when I click the button, you can see
that it toggles the its value using template
statement. And in this example, toggle text is
template statement. This statement context may
also refer to properties of the templates
own context. In the following example,
toggle text takes the templates own event
object as an argument. If you log that object,
you can see that it contains various information
about a target and the event that occurred.
Passing arguments can be very useful when you're
submitting the forms or looping through arrays,
and you need to access a specific element.
One odd here is that the context of a template
statement can be the component class instance, or
the template. Because of this, template statements
cannot refer to anything the global namespace,
such as window or document. For example, template
statement can call console log or math max.
pipes. pipes are simply functions you can use
in your templates to accept any input value
and return a formatted value. In this case,
you can see your data is untouched clay,
which is ready to be mold. At the beginning, it's
not very nice or clear what it's for. But with a
little bit of crafting and molding, you can get
the end result that you want. Angular provides
building pipes for typical data transformation
like bait pipe, uppercase pipe, currency pipe,
percent pipe, and similar. In my app component, I
will define a property with a value of new date.
If we just display our date object in our
template, you can see what kind of format we
get. It's not very user friendly. Now let's make
it nicer. To apply a pipe use the pipe operator
within a template expression along with the name
of the pipe, which is the date for the built in
date pipe now this is my more readable. One out
here, date pipe is executed only when it detects
a pure change to the input value. A pure change
is either a change a primitive input value such as
string, number, Boolean or symbol, or a change
object reference, such as date, array function,
or object. If you still don't like the
output format of your data, you can fine
tune it by using optional parameters. There are
predefined options like short or long, and others
or you can customize it completely. For
example, Allbright for ease for a day in a week
for EMS for a month, one lowercase D for an
A in a month and one lowercase y for a year.
You can also change multiple pipes as well, you
just add another pipe operator in a pipe name.
Now, we can create custom pipes as well. Let's
create a simple greetings by that will concatenate
hello to pass name. I'll use Angular Seelye to
generate this file for me. So type mg generate
pipe and the name is reading's pipe. In our
pipe, we have boilerplate code generated.
You can see that pipe decorator has been imported
with a name property, which we can use to call
our pipe in our templates. Also, there is a pipe
transform interface which needs to be implemented.
This interface requires the transform
method to be implemented. And this method
receives a value passed from a template. In our
case it will be a string. And the second parameter
is for optional params. From pipe itself.
return type in our case is going to be a string.
Now all we're going to do here is to concatenate
Hello wonder pastoring and return that.
Now in our template, we can call our custom pipe
with the greetings pipe name that we defined,
and I will pass world is our string. Now that's
how you create a custom pipes. Angular pipes are
very simple, but useful functionality provided
by Angular, and you will use them a lot. Once
again for a detailed list of all pipes check
the documentation link from the description.
Now let's discuss property binding. Property
binding moves a value in one direction. So you
can see is one way street. You can go the other
way. It goes from class property to target element
property. Property binding in Angular helps
you set values or properties of HTML elements
or directives. With property binding, you can
do things as toggle button functionality set
paths programmatically, and share values between
components. To bind the source property of an
image element to a components property plays a
target source in the square brackets followed by
an equal sign, and then the property.
The property here is item image URL.
Declare the item image URL property in
the class, in this case, app component.
A common point of confusion is between the
attribute call span and the property call span.
Notice that these two names
differ by only a single letter.
If you wrote something like this, you'll get the
template parse our interpolation and property
binding can set only properties, not attributes.
Instead, you'd use property binding and write it
like this. Another example is disabling a button
when the component says that it's unchanged.
To disable advanced functionality depending on a
boolean value, binding down disabled property to
a property in the class. That's true or false.
Because the value of the property is unchanged,
it's true in the app component
Angular disables the button.
Often interpolation in property
binding can achieve the same result.
The following binding pairs do the same thing.
One odd evaluation of a template expression should
have no visible side effects. You shouldn't be
assigning anything in the template expression
or using increment or decrement operators.
If you had an expression that changed the value
of something else that you were binding to,
the change of value would be a side effect.
Now let's see but our attribute, class and style
bindings. Using these bindings, you can improve
accessibility dynamically style your application
in update classes on the fly. First, let's talk
about attribute binding. Attribute binding in
your your helps you set values or attributes
directly. It is recommended that you set an
element property with a property binding whenever
possible. However, sometimes you don't have an
element property to bind. In those situations,
you can use attribute binding attribute binding
syntax resembles property binding, but instead of
an element property between brackets, you proceed
the name of the attribute with prefix ATR followed
by a dot. Then you set the attribute value
with an expression that resolves to a string.
Another common use case for attribute binding
is with the call span attribute in tables.
Mining the call span attribute helps you keep your
tables programmatically dynamic. Depending on the
amount of data that your application populates
a table with the number of columns their row
span could change. To use attribute binding
with the TD attribute coursepack specify the
call span attribute by using this syntax set
attribute called span equal to an expression.
In this example, we bind the call span
attribute to the expression one plus one.
This binding causes the table row to span two
columns. Sometimes there are differences between
the name of property and an attribute. Call span
is an attribute of table row, while call span with
the capital S is a property when using attribute
binding, use call span with a lowercase s.
For more information on how to bind to the cost
and property, check out the video about the
property binding. Now let's move to class binding.
You can use class binding to add and remove CSS
class names from an elements class attribute. To
create a single class binding use the prefix class
followed by a dot and the name of the CSS class.
Angular adds the class when the bound expression
on sale is truthy. And it removes the
class when the expression is faulty.
With the exception of undefined. To bind the
multiple classes use class set to an expression.
The expression can be one of a space
delimited string of class names.
An object class names as the keys and
30 old policy expressions as the values
an array of class names. With the object format,
angular adds a class only if its associated value
is truthy. And finally, let's talk about style
binding. You can use style binding to set styles
dynamically. To create a single style binding.
Use the prefix style followed by a.in the name
of the CSS style property, angular sets the
property to the value of the bound expression,
which is usually a string. Optionally, you can
add a unit extension like M or a percentage, which
requires a number type. You can write a style
property name in either dash case, or camel case.
To toggle multiple styles, bind to the
style attribute the style expression
the style expression can be one
of a string list of styles. Or
an object with style names is the
keys in style values as the values
and note that binding in the
rate to style is not supported.
This time I'm talking about event binding.
Event binding allows you to listen for and
respond to user actions such as keystrokes,
mouse movements, clicks and touches.
It's similar to float fishing as you're waiting
for a fish to take your bite. And once it drips
off, you respond quickly and strike. To bind an
event you use the angular event binding syntax.
The syntax consists of an event name within
parentheses to the left of an equal sign in
a template statement to the right. In this
example, the event name is click and the
template statement is unsaved. We can now
define the unsaved method. In RTS class.
And once we click our button, that event has been
bound and our method is executed. We can also bind
to custom events. To demonstrate that I'll create
an item details component. In this component, I'll
create an event emitter with output decorator,
which exposes our property to parent components.
Then I'll create a delete dummy method, which
will just emit our property once we call it.
Now, I'll define a button and
bind this method to a click event.
Next, I'll place our item details
component in our app component. And
I will bind to the Delete request
custom event that we just created.
I'm calling the lead item method. And I'll
use the event parameter to catch the string
sent with this event. And now I'll
define the Delete item method narrow
class and just log what we got. And
that's how you bind to custom event.
Now let's see two way binding connection.
Two Way binding is the concept of sharing
and giving. What you give is what you can expect
from others. Why to a binding to a binding gives
components in your application a way to share
data, use two way binding to listen for events
and update values simultaneously between parent
and child components. Angular is two way binding
syntax is a combination of square brackets in
parentheses. This syntax combines the brackets
of the property binding with the parentheses of
event binding. I'll create a sizer component.
In our component, I will define a size
value property in a size change event.
The size property is an input, so data can flow
into the size or component. The size change event
is an output, which allows data to flow out of
the size or component to the parent component.
Next, there are two methods that decrease the font
size and ink to increase the font size. These two
methods use Resize to change the value of the
size property within min max value constraints.
And to emit an event that
conveys the new size value.
In the sizer component template, I'll create two
buttons that each bind the click event to the
ink and deck methods. When the user clicks
one of the buttons the sizer components,
called the corresponding method. Both methods ink
and deck called the resize method with a plus one
or minus one, which in turn raises the site change
event with the new size value. And below them,
I'll add a label which displays the size
property in dynamically a bit its own font size.
In our root app component, I'll
include an app sizer component,
and I will use two way binding to bind font
size PX property to the size or component.
And below that, I'll add a div which will
utilize this property to adjust its text size.
In the app component, one size PX establishes
the initial size or component size value
by setting the value to 16. Clicking the
button at this the app component font size px,
the revised font size PX value updates style
binding, which makes the display text bigger or
smaller. The two way binding syntax is shorthand
for a combination of property binding and event
binding. The sizer component binding a separate
property binding. An event binding is as follows.
The event variable contains the data of the size
or component size change event. Angular assigns
the event value to app component font size
PX when the user clicks the buttons. To use
two way binding with Purim elements, we need mg
model which I will cover in the forum section.
Next ones are template variables. template
variables helps you to use data from one part of
a template. In another part of a template. It's
a variable that is created in an indentifies a
component or element within the template itself.
So it's like a phone number of a component,
which you can use to call in case you need
something from it. With template variables, you
can perform tasks such as respond to user input,
or finally tune your applications for syntax.
In the template, you use the hash
symbol to declare a template variable.
The following template variable phone declares
a form variable when an input element,
you can refer to a template variable
anywhere in the components template.
Here a button further down the template
refers to the form variable. Now we can
define the call form method and log the past
value, which is the actual value of the input.
So what is the template variable scope, you can
refer to a template variable anywhere within its
surrounding template. Structural directives such
as Angie and Angie for which we'll cover in the
later videos, or Angie template, act as a template
boundary, you cannot access template variables
outside of these boundaries. So can we
access variables in a nested template,
an inner template that can access template
variables that the outer template defines.
In the following example, changing the
text in the input changes the value in
the span because Angular immediately updates
changes to the template variable ref one.
In this case, there's an implied Angie
template around a span and a definition
of the variable is outside of it. So is the
same thing as binding explicitly like this.
However, accessing that template variable
from outside the parent template doesn't work
is the same as writing the following.
And that's all for template variables.
Now, let's discuss directives is the same as if
you are a CEO of the company. And you are giving
directives to your employees how to behave in what
to do in certain situations. What are directives.
directives are classes that add additional
behavior to elements in your Angular application.
with Angular built in directives, you can
manage forms, lists, styles, and what users see.
The different types of Angular directives are as
follows. Components directives with a template
this type of directive is the most common
directive type attribute directives. directives
that change the appearance or behavior of
an element component or another directive.
Structural directives, directives that
change the DOM layout by adding and removing
DOM elements. Today, we are talking about
built in attribute directives. Attribute
directive listens to and modify the behavior
of other HTML elements, attributes, properties,
and components. Many angii modules such as
router module and forms module, they find
their own attribute directives. The most common
attribute directives are as follows. mg class
adds and removes a set of CSS classes and G style
adds and removes its set of HTML styles. And model
adds two way data binding to an HTML form element.
How to add and remove classes with NGO class.
You can add or remove multiple CSS classes
simultaneously with mg class. To add or
remove a single class use class mining rather than
entry class. When the element you'd like to style,
add Angie class and set it equal to an expression.
In our class. Let's define you special as true
Because is special is true and reclass
applies the class of special to the diff.
To use NGO class with a method
add method to the component class.
In the following example, set current classes sets
the property current classes with an object that
adds or removes three classes based on the true or
false state of three other component properties.
Each key of the object is a CSS class name. If a
key is a true and your class as the class if a key
is false, and re class removes the class. Boolean
values are hard coded just for demonstration.
In the template, added the N g class property
binding to current class to set the elements
classes. And now we can preview our classes. Now
let's talk about mg style. You can use mg style
to set multiple inline styles simultaneously based
on the state of the component. To use edgy style
and the method to component class. Add empty
object current style. In the following example,
set current style says the property current
styles with an object that defines three styles
to set elements styles, and an energy style
property binding the current styles. For this
use case, angular applies the styles upon initial
annotations. And in case of changes. To do this,
the full example called set current
styles initially with NGOs in it.
And the last one in today's video is NGO
model, you can use the NGO model directive
to display a data property and update
that property. When the user make changes.
Input forms module and add it
to NGO modules import list.
I'll create a label and an input for this example.
Add an mg model binding of an HTML
form element and set it equal to the
property here its name. Now, if you define
property inside of our component class,
you can see how mg model directive
adds two way data binding to our input.
This mg model syntax can only set a data bound
property. When you write an Angular component,
you don't need a value accessor or mg
model if your name, the value and even
properties according to Angular to a binding
syntax. And that's all for this section.
In this section, we are continuing with Angular
directives. Let's build attribute directive. Let's
create a file highlight that directive.ts which
is the convention that you always should follow.
Next, import directive decorator from core and
implement that decorator with selector property.
For me, it's going to be app highlight.
Next, we want to export our class. And the last
thing we want is to import that in
our declarations array in app module.
That's our directive boilerplate code, which can
also get with the command mg generate directive
highlight. Import element ref from Angular core.
Element ref grants direct access to the host DOM
element through its native element property.
And element ref in the directive constructor
to inject a reference to host DOM element, the
element to which you apply app highlight. Add
logic to the highlight directive class that sets
the background to yellow. To use the highlight
directive add a paragraph element to the HTML
template with the directive as an attribute.
Angular creates an instance of highlight directive
class and inject in the reference to the paragraph
element into directive constructor, which has
the P elements background style to yellow.
Now, let's see how to detect when a user
mouse's into or out of the element and to
respond by setting or clearing the highlight
color. Import host listener from Angular core
Add it to event handlers that respond
when the mouse enters or leaves,
each with a host listener decorator. With the host
listener decorator, you can subscribe to events of
the DOM element that hosts an attribute
directive. The paragraph in this case,
the handlers delegate to a helper method highlight
that says the color on the host DOM element L.
The background color appears when the
pointer hovers over the paragraph element
and disappears as the pointer moves
out. Now, let's see how we can make
the directive dynamic to be able to use it
at different places with different colors.
In highlight directive Ts File, Import input from
Angular core, add an app highlight input property.
The input decorator adds metadata to
the class that makes the directive app
highlight property available for binding.
In app component Ts add a color property
to the app component. To simultaneously applied
the directive and the color. Use the property
binding with the app highlight directive selector
setting to equal to color. The app highlight
attribute binding performs two tasks applies the
highlighting directive to the paragraph element
and sets directive highlight color with the
property binding. And that's all for this one.
This is the last section about directives.
So let's see what are structural directives.
Structural directives are responsible for HTML
layout. They shape or reshape the dome structure,
typically by adding removing and
manipulating the host elements
to which they're attached. This section introduces
the most common built in structure directives.
mg conditionally creates or disposes of sub
views from the template and you for repeat a
note for each item in a list. And you switch a set
of directives that switch among alternative views.
You can add or remove an element by applying an mg
if directive to a host element. When Ngf is false,
angular removes an element and
its descendants from the DOM.
Angular then disposes of their components,
which frees up memory in resources to add or
remove an element by the engine if they condition
expression such as is active in this example.
vendor is active expression returns a
true value Ngf as the div to the DOM.
When the expression is false, he Ngf removes
the dim from the DOM. That's simpler right.
Now let's talk about mg four. You can use the
NG g4 directive to present a list of items.
Let's create an array of objects
with the name property in it.
Define a block of HTML that determines how Angular
renders a single item. to list your items assigned
the shorthand lead item of items to energy for
the string lead item of items instructs Angular
to do the following. Store each item in the
items array in the local item looping variable,
make each item available to the template HTML for
each iteration. Translate lead item of items into
energy template around the host element. Repeat
the energy template for each item in the list. By
the way, you can get the index of energy for in a
template input variable in use it in the template
in the NG g4, add a semicolon and let
i equals to index to the shorthand.
The following example guys the index in a variable
named I in these days it within the item name.
And the less directive which
we are going to talk about
is switch like the JavaScript switch
statement. And just switch displays
one element from among several possible
elements based on a switch condition.
Angular puts only the selected element into the
DOM. And g switch is a set of three directives.
And you switch an attribute directive that
changes the behavior of its companion directives
and j switch case structure directive that adds
its element to the DOM. When it's bound value
equals to switch value and removes
its bound value when it doesn't equal
the switch value. Andrey switch default structural
directive that adds its element to the DOM.
When there is no selected energy switch case, I'll
modify the items array to be just a single item.
On an element such as I do, add Angie switch
bound to an expression that returns
the switch value such as a name.
Though the name value in this example is a
string, the switch value can be of any type
bind to mg speech case and mg speech
to default on the LMS for the cases.
And now depending on the value of the
item name rendering on the page changes.
If it didn't provide a case for the
name value, default will be executed.
Next, we are discussing dependency injection.
dependencies are services or objects that a class
needs to perform its function. dependency
injection, or di is a design pattern in which
a class request dependencies from external sources
rather than creating them. You can look at it as
if you're adding an extension to your browser,
or adding an app to a phone. Once you add it,
you provide yourself with the new functionalities
and features nice extension. Let's create a
service which we can inject in our components.
Create a new file with the name log.service.ts.
Import injectable decorator from Angular core.
And then for provided in metadata add root value,
which means that we are going to provide
the service in the root of the application
and that is visible throughout the application.
export our log service class and inside of this
service, we want to add our log message
method, which will just log past messages.
For clarity in meeting ability, it is recommended
that you define components and services
in separate files now inject our log service into
the app module file in providers array. injecting
service results in making them visible to a
component. to inject a dependency in components
constructor supply a constructor argument
with dependency type. The following example
specifies the lock service, the app component
constructor to type of log service is log service.
Now we can reference our log service in
our component and call our method from it
should pass our message and as you can
see it's being executed. As expected.
We can use this approach to inject third party
libraries in other modules that are available
in the angular framework. So let's inject render
to module which is used for custom rendering
and updating the DOM. Import render to from
Angular core and injected inside the constructor.
Also, we will need element ref, which we
can use for referencing our DOM elements,
or the host component in our case.
Now inside the NG on init lifecycle,
call the set style method of the renderer and
set the color of host native element to red.
This method changes the color of our components
tax. And as you can see, with the dependency
injection, we get access to more features
and methods. That's all there is to it.
Next is very important topic. routing. The
angular router is a core part of Angular platform.
It enables developers to build single page
applications with multiple views. In the
navigation between these views. We can compare
routing of our obligations with navigating
a plane. Pilot says the flight
coordinates in our case route path,
and the plane lands on the desired location
or desire page in our app. Oftentimes,
planes carries goods or cargo and routes
carry params info in data. And unfortunately,
some things do get crashed or lost.
And for route sometimes we get 404
To use the angular router, an application needs
to have at least two components so that it can
navigate from one to the other. To create a
component using the COI, enter the following
at the command line, where first is the name of
your component, and G generate component. First,
repeat this step for a second component or give
it a different name. Here the new name is second.
This guide works with a CI
generated Angular application.
If you're working manually, make sure that
you have base href would slash in the head
of your index HTML file. This assumes that
the app folder is the application route
and that uses slash create a new module for
routing named app dash routing dot module.
We find const routes which is type of routes.
Here we will define our paths and components.
Inside NGO module imports array add router
module in call for route module it routes passed
as argument, then export the router module
so it can be imported into the route module.
At the end, define the app routing module class
imported app routing module into app
module and add it to the imports array.
Now define your routes in your routes array. Each
route in this array is a JavaScript object that
contains two properties. The first property bath
defines the URL path for the route. The second
property component defines the component that
Angular should use for the corresponding path.
Now that you have defined your routes,
you can add them to your application.
First, add links to the two components.
assigned an anchor tag that you want to
add the rod to the router link attribute.
Set the value of the attribute to the component
to show when a user clicks on each link.
Next, update your component template
to include router outlet. This element
informs Angular to update the application view
with the component for the selected route.
You can add router link active activity if you
want to style active link. One Note the order
of routes is important because the router uses a
first match wins strategy when matching routes.
So more specific routes should be placed about
less specific routes. Often is a user navigator
application, you want to pass information from
one component to another. To do so you use the
activated route interface. First input router
activated route in para map to your component.
inject an instance of activated route by
adding it to your applications constructor.
Update the NGO own init method to access the
activator route and track the ID parameter.
Now we need to adjust our routes
to pass the ID params as well.
In that add semi colon and name of your parameter.
And then we can add ID values to our links.
That's how you pass in retrieve
data from one component to another.
A well functioning application should gracefully
handle when user attempts to navigate to a part of
your application that doesn't exist. To add this
functionality to your application. You set up a
wildcard route. The angular route selects this
route anytime the requested URL doesn't match
any router paths. To set up a wildcard route,
add the following code to your routes definition.
For the component property, you can
define any component in your application.
Common choices include an application
specific page not found component.
But here I'm just redirecting
to the first component.
And now if you navigate to any random path,
it will always give us first component.
As your application grows more complex, you
may want to create routes that are relative
to the component other than your route
component. These types of nested routes
are called child routes. This means
you're adding a second router outlet to
app because it is in addition to the router
outlet in app component. In this example,
there are two additional child components child
a and child b. here first component has its own
nav, and a second router outlet in
addition to the one in app component.
Also, I'm going to create two child routes
with the router links of child a child B
and give it a second router link.
Now I'll create two additional component with
Angular ccli in named their child a component
and child B component.
Each other route is like any other route, in
that it needs both a path and a component.
The one difference is that you place child routes
in a children array within the parent route.
Now if you navigate to any of child routes,
we get the corresponding child component.
Use route guards to prevent users from navigating
to parts of an application without authorization.
The following route guards are available in
Angular can activate connect to a child can
deactivate, resold and can load create a service
for your guard. mg generate guard your guard.
In your guard class implement the guard you
want to use the following example users can
activate to guard the route. Now depending
on your logic, it can return true or false.
Usually it's checks if the user is logged in,
or does he have privileges to access the page
in your routing module, use the appropriate
property in your routes configuration here
can activate tells the router to mediate
navigation to this particular route.
Now, if you set the guard too fast, we
can't access the route. Otherwise, we can.
And that's all for routing for this section.
After this one, we're covering one even more
important concept, and that is angular forms.
Let's start off with template driven forms. I
know it sounds impossible, but there were times
when there was no internet or even computer.
So in those times, we had to fill out good old
paper forms when we wanted to visit a doctor or
to apply for various personal documents. So web
forms are nothing different except their digital.
NGO supports two design approaches for interactive
forms. template driven forms are suitable for
small or simpler forms. While reactive forms are
more scalable and suitable for complex forms. This
tutorial shows you how to build a form from
scratch. First, import forms module in your
app root module. Let's first build our bad class
which defines a data model reflected in our form.
High will have three properties ID name is PC.
Now let's import our class in the app component.
Define a species in species array. Now create a
model from the battle. Last in pass the values
for our path. Here we're using
dummy data. But in your real app,
you would use a service to get the data from the
API and to save it. Also, let's add submitted
property, which will change depending on
the state of the form and on submit method.
Next in our HTML file, we will create
a form that reflects our data model.
Create a form and inside two
divs for two fields. First,
we'll be naming input. And I'm adding a
label and required attribute to our input.
And the second one will be a cell Act,
which will loop through an array of species
to show all the values from the array.
Same as for input, I'm adding a label for our
select. And also I'll add the required attribute.
Then I will use mg for tillow to
do all the values and display them.
If you run the application right now,
you'll see the list of species in the
selection control. The input elements are not
yet bound to data values or events. So they are
still blank and have no behavior. The next
step is to bind the input controls to the
corresponding bad properties with two way
data binding so that they respond to the user
input by updating the data model, and also
respond to programmatic changes in the data
by updating the display. The NGO model directive
declared in the forms module, lets you bind
controls in your template driven form to
properties in your data model. Add the energy
model directive using two way data binding syntax
for the name use model dot name. And for species
use model dot species value. When you use
Angie model on element, you must define
a name attribute for that element. Angular uses
the assigned name to register the element with
the energy form directive attached to the parent
form element. So in order to register our form,
add a template reference variable use the value
of MG form. The platform template variable
is now a reference to the NG g form directive
instance that governs the form as a whole.
In order to test our application plays the
model object in our template with a JSON pipe.
Now if you update your foreign films,
you will see that model is being updated.
Now the user should be able to submit this form
after filling it, create a submit button on the
bottom. the submit button at the bottom of the
form does nothing on its own, but it does trigger
us form submit event because of its type Submit.
To respond to this event. Take the following
steps. bind the forms mg submit event property
to the platform component. on submit method.
Use the template reference variable bedform.
To access the form that contains the submit
button and create an event binding. You
will bind the form property that indicates
its overall validity to the Submit buttons
disabled property. run the application now.
Notice that the button is enabled. Although
it doesn't do anything useful yet. Delete the
name value. This file is the required rule so
disable the submit button. The show I response
to form submission you can hide the data entry
area in this place something else in its place.
Wrap the entire form in a deal in bind it's hidden
property to the app component submitted property.
The main form is visible from the start
because the submitted property is false
until you submit the form as this fragment
from the app component chose to show something
else while the form is in submitted state add
the following HTML below the new div wrapper
add the properties that you
updated in the edit button.
If the user wants to update the fields again.
And now let's preview how it works.
That's all about template driven forms.
Now in the next section, we're going to see
how we can take more control of our forms
and how to create reactive forms.
Reactive forms provide a model driven approach
to handling form inputs, whose values change over
time. Each change to the form state returns
a new state, which maintains the integrity
of the model between changes. Let's add basic form
control. To use reactive form controls, import
reactive forms module from Angular forms package
and added to your NGO modules import array.
To register a single form control, import a form
control class and create a new instance of form
control to save as a class property. Use the
constructor of form control to set its initial
value, which in this case is an empty string. By
creating these controls in your component class,
you get immediate access to listen for update
and validate the state of the form input.
After you create a control in the component class,
you must associate it with a form control element
in the template Are they the template with a
form control using the form control binding
provided by form control directive, which is
also included in the reactive forms module.
Using the template binding syntax,
the form control is now registered to
the name input element in the template, you
can display the value in the following ways
through the value changes observable very can
listen for changes in the form of value in the
template using async pipe or in the component
class using the subscribe method or with the
value property, which gives you a snapshot of the
current value. The following example shows you how
to display the current value using interpolation.
In the template. The displayed value changes as
you update the form control element. Reactive
forms have methods to change it controls value
programmatically, which gives you the flexibility
to update the value without user interaction.
The following example as a method to the component
class to update the value of the control to Nancy
using the set value method. Update the template
button button to simulate a name update.
When you click the Update name button, the value
entered in the form control element is reflected
as its current value. The form model is the source
of truth for the control. So when you click the
button, the value of the input is change within
the component class, overriding its current value.
Form stabilty contains several related
controls. Reactive forms provide two ways
of grouping multiple related controls into
a single input form. First way of form group
defines a form with a fixed set of controls
that you can manage together. And second way
of form array defines a dynamic form where
you can add and remove controls at runtime.
import the form group and form control classes
from the angular forms package. Create a property
in the component class name profile form, and
set the property to a new form group instance.
to initialize the form group provide a
constructor with an object of named keys
mapped to their control. For the profile form
add to form control instances with the names
first name and last theme. The individual
form controls are not collected within a
group. After you define a model, you must update
the template to reflect the model in the view.
I'm adding two inputs and two labels that
match our model. The form control name input
provided by the form control name directive binds
each individual input to the form control defined
in the form group. The forum comm directive
lessons for the Submit event, immediate buy
the form element and emits an mg submit event
that you can bind to a callback function.
Add an mg submit event listener to the form
tag with the on submit callback method.
The onsubmit method captures the
current value of profile form.
Here, you will just log the form value.
The submit event is emitted by the form tag
using the native Dom event, you trigger the
event by clicking a button in submit type. This
allows the user to press the Enter key to submit
the completed form. Add a button to the bottom
of the form to trigger the form submission.
And that's all for reactive forms. In the next
section, we're going to see how we can improve
our forms. So in this section,
we're covering form validation.
This tutorial will show you how to validate
user input from the UI and display useful
validation messages in both reactive and template
driven forms. Anything that you want to store to
your database needs to have multiple levels
of validation and AC validation the same as
if you're at an audition, or job interview
something or whether someone is presenting
to you and you decide will he pass or not.
To add validation to a template driven form,
you add the same validation attributes as you
would with native HTML form validation. Angular
uses directives to match these attributes with
validator functions in the framework. Every
time the value of a form control changes, anger
runs validation, and generates either a list of
validation errors that results in an invalid
status or not. It results in a valid status.
I'll create a name string field
inside of our component class.
Then in our HTML file, I'll add an input text
field with required attribute me length of four.
I'm binding name input property to energy model,
and I'm exporting energy model
to a local variable called main
engine model mirrors many of the properties
of its underlying form control instance.
So can use this template to check for
control states such as valid and dirty.
The mgf of the div element reveals
a set of nested messages they have,
but only if the name is invalid, and
the control is either dirty or touched.
Each nested they have can present a custom
message for one of the possible validation errors.
These are messages for acquired admin lead.
Now if we type something and leave the field
empty, we will get the validation error message.
And the same goes if we enter value
less than four characters long.
In a reactive form, the source
of truth is a component class.
Instead of adding validators
through attributes in the template,
you add validator function directly to the
form control model in the component class.
The same built in validators that are
available as he was in template driven forms,
such as required and min length are all available
to use as functions from the validator class.
To update the validation form to be a reactive
form, use some of the same built in validators.
In this example, the name control
sets up to a built in validators
validators required in validators min length.
These validators are synchronous, so
they are passed as the second argument.
Notice that you can support multiple
validators by passing the functions
in as an array. This example also adds
a getter method. In a reactive form,
you can always access any form control
through the get method on its parent
group. But sometimes it's useful to define
and getters. It's shorthand for the template.
In our template, add form group to our form.
And now, only thing that we need to
change in our template to make it reactive
is to remove Angie Murrell and to bide
our name control to form control name.
This forum differs from the template driven
version in that delong exports any directives.
Instead, it uses the name gatter
defined in the component class,
known as the required attribute
is still present in the template.
Although it's not necessary for validation, it
should be retained for accessibility purpose.
We finally came to the end of this long tutorial,
and we're going to cover communication using HTTP
client. Imagine that you're running a TV
station or a newspaper. And what if you
lose communication to reporters, you would end
up with a blank newspaper or no news broadcasts
is the same thing with web apps. Without backend
communication, our apps will be bad without
informations or instructions on the back end.
Most front end applications need to communicate
with a server over HTTP protocol to download or
upload data and access other backend services.
Before we can use HTTP client, you need
to import Angular HTTP client module.
Most apps do so in the root app module.
Let's create data service. Most common use
case is to inject HTTP client into service.
In use it throughout the application, you can
then inject HTTP client service as a dependency
of an application class, as shown in this example.
Now let's see how we can fetch data from a server.
To do that, we're going to use HTTP client get
method. First inject HTTP client into our service.
Then create get data method and inside
of this method will fetch our data.
the get method takes two arguments the endpoint
URL from which to fetch and an options object
that you use to configure the request to add
things like parameters to your request. For this
tutorial, I found a free cocktail API service.
The link will be in the description box below,
enter the URL, and no additional
parameters are required in this case.
Now in our app component, we inject
the data service in the constructor
inside of MG on init method, let's call our
get data method. Because the service method
returns an observable, the component
subscribes to the methods return value.
I'm just gonna console log in. And
that's how you get data from the server.
In an ideal world, everything works as a magic.
But we don't live in an ideal world, fortunately,
and we lose connection with API sometimes. So we
need to handle errors when they come up. If the
request fails on the server, HTTP client returns
an error object instead of a successful response.
Let's add a pipe on our get method
and use cash error to catch it.
I'm going to log the error for development purpose
and return throw error with some message. They
should be used in your obligation to show the user
that his request has failed. Without notification,
they wouldn't know what's happening. And
don't forget to import missing packages.
Now we can change the URL to break the request.
And to see the error, we usually don't want to
see this view in our obligations. But we
need to be ready for that when it happens.
HTTP client besides get also has a POST method for
submitting data to server. For example, if you are
submitting a form, we have delete requests
for deleting data from database obviously,
a pull request which replaces a resource with
updated data. Now, most of the API's require an
authentication key with their requests. So let's
see how we can add that I found this Lord of Rings
database which requires an auth key. Let's create
HTTP options object with the headers property.
This property will be a new HD We had this
object, and we will pass two properties.
Content Type is application JSON, which means that
we're using JSON as content and authorization,
where we enter our API key barrier is
type of authorization, and follow by key.
In order to get your personal key you need to
register link is in the description box below.
Now, are they the API endpoint. And if you try
to call it without passing the HTTP options,
you can see that we get an error. What if we
add authorization the request is successful.
Congratulations, you watch all the way through the
end. This was very long tutorial and I hope you
learned a lot of new things. Also, don't forget
to subscribe to Free Code Camp. And if you want
to see more tutorials like this, don't forget
to check out my channel. My name is Slobodan,
and I'll see you guys in one of the next
videos or tutorials. Take care. Until then.